johnson and his team were still drunk
on the post-brexit euphoria
thinking they could walk on water
and hadn't done the hard work required
in relation to getting ready from basic
stuff like lack of
ppe to
not ordering the face mask to not making
face masks compulsory early enough had
the government acted sooner
and acted uh in a different way
i think fewer lives have been lost
[Music]
what was your childhood like what was
that a young city khan like
i've got to be honest i had a great
childhood i mean looking back now ye of
course it was tough and all the rest of
you but it didn't feel tough you know
there was eight of us i got three
brothers older three brothers younger
and i got sister who's older mom and dad
we lived in a three-bedroom council
place in south london the henry clinton
state
and
we didn't think we lived in overcrowded
accommodation we didn't think it was a
big deal uh doing your homework on the
floor what do you think is a big deal
it's only later on you realize that
people are in bedrooms or they've got a
desk to do their homework on
or they've got gardens and so i had a
great childhood i mean it was it was
tough um made you street wise
looking back now people say you went to
a tough school
it didn't feel tough when you're there i
mean many of my best friends now are
still mates from uh school
some of my mates you know didn't end up
as well uh some of them did go to prison
some of them getting involved in
criminality and stuff but you know i was
blessed great teachers you know great
life at home good friends um and i still
live in the area i still live in the
same area the joke is i was born in
tooting raised in tuition married into
it and i'll probably die there as well i
hope hopefully not too soon what was it
that made you want in the politics when
i was 15
a number of things happened my dad's bus
garage has been closed down because of
uh improvisation from thatcher
my teachers were
in an industrial action because of cuts
from the government and so they stopped
doing
football and cricket at the weekends as
part of the industrial action
and lots of my mates big brothers in
particular uh
were regularly you know stopped and
searched under the old sus laws by the
police so all those things you know made
me very angry and the issue is how do i
channel the anger
and i thought the idea of being the mp
for my community that i was born and
raised in was the only reason i'd walk
away from
my legal career you know my firm doing
the law that i did
because of the chance to represent my
community in parliament
why did you decide you wanted to be
mayor of london
it's the best job in politics basically
you work hard you get a help in hand you
can achieve anything that's the that's
the london promise but too many
londoners are working hard they're not
getting help in hand and they're not
fulfilling their potential and i wanted
to be somebody who can provide the help
in hand by being the mayor of this uh
great city
i was also if i'm honest frustrated by
being a parliamentarian even when i was
you know in government attending cabinet
in parliament you got to work in silos
and you gotta you know understand the
hierarchy um you know if you're
minister for transport you're only
talking about transport you can't get
involved in other people's lanes in
their silos
when you're the mayor
you can go all over the place you're in
charge of everything
and you're the boss and you can do stuff
whether it's you know fixing housing
crisis whether it's
improving air quality whether it's
investing in youth services whether it's
you know
standing up for those londoners who are
heartbroken and devastated and depressed
because our country invites us leave the
eu giving them a sense of belonging so
the opportunities
as a mayor
are infinite
i've been married during an incredibly
hard time in london's history what's
been the single hardest day for you
well somebody once said to me recently
actually i mean you've had everything
the only thing missing is uh is a plague
of locusts i mean it's being you know
i'm not so i'm not suggesting that i'm
moses or we live in egypt um but it's
been tough in 2017 a number of things
you know four terrorist attacks the
awful grenfell uh tower uh fire
uh you then got the the pandemics i
think you know
getting the phone call about grenfell
tower was awful seeing the images uh
going there the next morning seeing the
smoke coming out me and the families
uh in real time you know living through
the terror attacks in westminster bridge
london bridge not knowing
you know what's going on and that's when
your
preparation your planning kicks in you
know you've got a good team around you
it's really important to have a good
team around you i never switch off you
know i'm seven days a week 24 hours a
day as on my team but you mentioned
there about about the pandemic you
remember the moment when you were like
all of our lives are going to change
yeah i remember vividly i mean what
happened was so so initially johnson
wasn't inviting me to any of the cobra
meetings so that they were four or five
i mean forget not inviting me he didn't
bother to go to some of them um
and so we were in the dark as to what
was going on in london and the first
time i went it was a monday and i was
like for me it's like bloody hell i mean
the numbers
it's obvious that we're the capital city
uh you know and people have come to
london and we're we're super spreaders
we are a super spreader right we are
city zero uh for the uk and there was
sort of relaxed attitude from johnson
and his team and i didn't understand it
and it was obvious to me
where this was heading because i was
speaking to colleagues around the world
i was trying to explain that lives are
going to be lost and this is going to be
you know going to go into lockdown and
stuff and and that's when it started
sinking in um that this is
it for the long term um the consequences
are going to be stock in relation to
lives and livelihoods lost
potentially our city would never be the
same again and actually i didn't then
think that would be two years i thought
we'd talk about weeks maybe months
um i i didn't predict you know two years
on we're now slowly starting to come out
of the pandemic years i mean the
laxative attitude of johnson and his
team uh
begged belief then
and when you look at the numbers of
deaths and how ill-prepared we were and
here's the thing
the pandemic had started around the
globe right so we could see what was
happening in the far east from china
we've gone to italy
so
we weren't the first mover so we could
see what was happening we could avoid
the mistakes others had made
had made and learn from the successes we
didn't do any of that and and i think i
think you know johnson and his team were
still drunk
on the post-brexit euphoria
thinking they could walk on water
and hadn't done the hard work required
in relation to getting ready from basic
stuff like lack of
ppe to
um you know having the nhs radio not
having the right ventilators to
not ordering the face mask to not making
face masks compulsory early enough to
not closing down
uh you know
people mixing and mingling passing on
this virus and so forth and look and i
said i remember saying to boris johnson
look you're a libertarian i'm somebody
who's passionate about human rights if
the both of us
are saying
let's lock down people will see there
must be a serious reason people then act
but had the government acted sooner
and acted uh in a different way
i think fewer lives have been lost
another very difficult time um which was
the murder of sarah everard we've
recently used this campaign aim to end
violence against women and girls can you
tell us a little bit about
why you're launching this campaign
well
i think those of us who who are men uh
and boys
need to have the humility to
realize that our life experiences are
very different to the life experiences
of women and girls simple things like
you know
those blokes watching this like me when
we use the tube
uh you know people aren't touching us up
people aren't taking photographs of our
skirts
we don't have to change the footwear so
we can run faster if we are being
followed or have keys in our hands in
case we need to clench our fist and
punch or to open the door quickly
we aren't imposing on ourselves a curfew
so we can't go after a certain time
because it's not safe because it's uh
dark
and sarah was abducted very near from my
home actually where we go for a walk and
i remember my daughters my wife and i
walking around there and seeing the
posters
on the trees and the lampposts because
amazed at a brilliant job during the
time she was missing trying to raise
awareness and in fact the the road she
was abducted from
by the servant police officers wrote
that i know uh very well so it was
personal for obvious reasons
but also i think
men need to reflect upon the fact that
it's our behavior
which about violence against women and
girls is from men
and so and i think misogyny is linked
with violence and we may think sometimes
it's banter we're just having fun but
that's not how it's received by women
and girls so the campaign is one with a
lot of work talking to and listening to
women and girls and experts
um as well as men
and it's aimed at men frankly speaking
and you know we need to be good allies
of women and uh girls not not to be a
bystander when we see bad things
happening or whether it's ourselves
behaving in an appropriate way or
whether it's our mates or people we know
looking back on sarah was just over a
year ago now when you look back on it
is there anything that you regret from
that time
yeah a lot of things
in relation to this i think the police
response to the vigil
i'm not quite clear at the time i think
the police got it wrong particularly
when we've since discovered that you
know up the road uh the the the rule
makers the lawmakers were breaking them
right at a time and what women and girls
wanted to do was to show solidarity to
sarah and to remember all those who had
uh lost
uh their lives and that there are other
things i think you know we could have
done differently in relation to what
we've since discovered
about how the police don't vet properly
those they take on uh about the fact
that the you know there's a culture uh
that is in the police where overt overt
sexism misogyny racism homophobic
discrimination seems to be acceptable in
relation to this and you know one of the
reasons why i made clear to
uh the commissioner uh that i'd lost
confidence in her was because it's quite
clear
that what the what the leadership
wasn't comprehending
was that there are deep cultural issues
in the police service that leads to
over racism sex and misogyny
discrimination homophobia but also the
lack of plan a lack of a plan
to win back the trust of confidence of
londoners uh which is desperately needed
when you're pleased by consent we need
to make sure that you know sexual
harassment in a public place is a
criminal offense we've got to give the
cps the police
uh the criminal justice system the
resources that they need and so forth
and so you know it's not just a policing
issue and and what we're doing from city
hall now
is to try and prevent the best way to
reduce violence against women and girls
is to prevent it going in the first
place so it's not just a policing issue
important though they are crucial they
are we've also got to make sure there's
prevention that there's action against
perpetrators and we've got to stop that
spreading
i think we focus on a lot of the the
hardest parts of your job
what what's the best bit of your job
well listen i've got i got to be honest
i thought as a mayor i was being invited
here to take part in the snack awards
now listen it's great listen the best
part of the job is just meeting old new
londoners i mean it's just i can't i
mean every day i hear a story about
somebody whose lives been transformed by
our city sometimes by our policies i
mean it is a remarkable job you meet you
could meet forget
you know no two days are the same no two
hours at the same time you know we are a
city where and people don't realize this
um you know more than 300 uh
uh countries of origin you know are
londoners we are the most diverse city
in the world strength
as far as i'm concerned not not a
weakness and you know we've seen in
relation to londoners response forget
our government londoner's response
to what's happening in ukraine uh some
of the best of our city and you know i
love it
what do you do for fun i love football
uh i love playing tennis i love going
for a run we've got a dog luna who we
love uh
going out um
hoping to see the batman very soon uh
going to the theater
uh i've got tickets for weller coming up
and michael keownaku so liverpool this
season they're in still on the hunt for
the quadruple
do you think they'll do it i think
they'll pull it off
my heart says yes my head says no i mean
you know for me
premier league champions league give up
the fa cup
and then you're jurgen klopp
would jurgen klopp make a great prime
minister
yeah
put on what makes him a leader what
makes him real well listen listen you
can't but watch a clop interview not
smile at the end of it uh you know he's
infectious he's charismatic
he's he's a hugger he brings people
together he brings the best of people
um it shows that you can be a successful
leader
and be a decent guy
message for you boris johnson
who's your favorite player ever
ever ever all time just one i can't do
one oh god yeah
douglas but the idol is you know dog
leash and rush then you've got souness
then you bring in johnny barnes and
stevie g i'll play on the right as well
uh i probably put allison in girl and
not not clements or grubbler but yeah
when you go to the pub what's your drink
of choice diet coke no i spit 11. what's
your favorite film ever
oh good one
um
it's gonna be the rockies one two and
three
um
yeah four's not bad the rush of things
are bad i met dolph lundgren nice guy
why don't you meet dolph logan yeah well
on one of the joys of my job is you you
spent half an hour being uh
cross-examined by piers morgan and
susana reed and the quid pro quo as you
meet darth langer is about to come and
be interviewed as well he's huge listen
everyone's huge to me even though sal is
huge to me uh but dolph longwood is huge
really nice guy though
who do you want to be the next james
bond
uh riz ahmed
killian murphy or idris sober one of the
three who is your favorite member of the
conservative party
one who's lost an election
um actually i mean of current mps like i
i quite like nadeem sahabi i like sajda
javed actually as you know put aside the
politics and stuff
uh ed vaizey i get with really well i
mean listen i mean people think we hate
each other we you know we sometimes we
do but you know an opponent is not
necessarily an enemy and uh we try and
get on you know behind the scenes and
stuff and you know uh it's not true to
say we hate each other
some i do though
i won't ask you who uh last question
world cup year this year are you gonna
win it yeah i think the key thing is is
to pick trenton this time don't miss
them around uh you know
you know as an extra player and stuff i
think we can do it the experience two
semi-finals in relation to a world cup
and uh the euros you know bodes well for
us and don't forget this summer is the
women's euros uh finals in london and so
wouldn't that be a great springboard for
the for the blokes later on this year
aged about 13
my dad was at the hospital i was at home
with the other kids and he phoned me to
say
your mum's not gonna make it
and then he said can you tell the others
and
that was pretty tough for a 13 year old
to try to contemplate